Speaker 1: . Last night, incumbent Republican
Florida Senator Marco Rubio was brutally crushed
in a disastrous debate for him by challenger,
Democratic Congresswoman Val Demings.
I have not seen a debate like this in a long
time, and we've covered now close to a dozen
different 20, 22 debates live on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook, as we tend to do.
I have not seen such a one sided debate until
last night's debate where Val Demings just
crushed Rubio.
He looked despondent at certain points.
I also will mention Rubio seemed not only
like he didn't want to be there, but sort
of like he didn't think he needed to be there.
His attitude, the entire debate was that Val
Demings is sort of beneath him.
Why does he have to waste his time as the
incumbent senator debating this lowly other
individual?
And she really crushed him now.
Before we look at some clips I will mention.
Demings wasn't perfect.
She definitely wasn't perfect.
There were a few moments where she gave Rubio
very good openings for easy and effective
rebuttals.
And you heard from the crowd that they were
effective.
There were some moments that just weren't
perfect, but she was really, really good.
Demings came out very, very hot after Rubio
accused her of never having passed any legislation.
Let's just jump, jump right into this.
This is very interesting.
Speaker 2: He's been in Congress for over
half a decade.
She's never passed a bill, not TPP, not anything,
not a single bill she's passed has ever become
law.
I'm proud of the fact we saved millions of
jobs.
I'm proud of the fact we did it in a bipartisan
way.
Speaker 3: That's not true.
I know the senator look and I'm really disappointed
in you, Marco Rubio, because I don't I think
there was a time when you did not lie in order
to win.
I don't know what happened to you.
You know that is not true.
My first term in this in the United States
House, I passed legislation to help law enforcement
officers with mental health programs.
Your first term in the Senate, you voted to
turn Medicare into basically to abolish it
and then turn it into an underfunded voucher
program.
And then you gave the biggest tax break to
the richest of the rich and said you'd pay
for it with cuts to Social Security and Medicare.
Speaker 1: Now, not only was she very much
prepared for these attacks, Val Demings chose
to do something interesting during the debate
while Marco Rubio continued to basically address
the moderators.
MODERATOR Val Demings regularly turned to
Marco Rubio and directly addressed him now
in our live chat.
There were some people who said, this is not
a good approach.
It's coming off as too aggressive and confrontational.
Val Demings is trying to play from behind
here and we'll look at the polling in a bit.
I actually think that this was exactly right,
because when she would do that, when she would
turn to Rubio, Rubio visibly shrank away.
He he he shrank away from the confrontation.
Let's look at more clips.
And these are these really are good.
Here's just another these don't really.
Necessarily introductions.
Speaker 3: Of course, the senator who has
never run anything at all but his mouth.
Oh, wouldn't know nothing about helping people
and being there for people when they are in
trouble.
No one plant the pandemic.
Pandemic, but our response to it is everything.
Individuals were hurting, families were hurting,
businesses were hurting.
We passed the CARES Act, which the Senator
supported.
There were some problems in the CARES Act
with the Paycheck Protection Program that
you'd love to take credit for.
Some say it was poorly written.
Some say it didn't help the people that it
was supposed to didn't save the jobs that
it was supposed to.
There was a way to fix the problems in the
pipe through the American rescue plan and
help people that were in trouble.
But you played politics, Senator, and you
did not do that.
Your number one job as a United States senator
is to protect the health, safety and well-being
of the American people.
You've been at it for 24 years, of course.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
She had a very good mix of passion, but also
very specific claims from Marco Rubio's legislative
past or lack thereof.
This came up again during the topic of prescription
drugs, and it's just hard to say anything
other than Demings was prepared, and Rubio
seemed resentful of even having to be there.
Speaker 3: He talked about pharmaceuticals.
He voted against legislation that would help
reduce the costs of prescription drugs and
help cap the cost of cancelation.
Speaker 1: And Rubio again, it seemed that
he was unsure how to respond.
Now, one of the other interesting things about
Val Demings is they can't go after her with
one of the really popular slogans of 2022,
which is you're part of this defund the police
movement.
Demings was a police officer, a police detective
and a police chief, and her credentials as
a supporter of law enforcement while also
supporting reform, make it very difficult
to attack her on those lines.
And when the topic of gun violence came up,
the difference in not only knowledge but even
commitment to dealing with gun violence was
palpably different.
Speaker 3: Majority of people in our nation
want us to do just that.
How long will you watch people being gunned
down in first grade, fourth grade, high school,
college, church, synagogue, a grocery store,
a movie theater, a mall and a nightclub.
Speaker 2: Congressmen do.
Speaker 4: Nothing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and that was a critical moment
of the debate, in fact, where I think it sort
of turned Rubio seemed almost defeated after
that point.
His only real successes after that point in
the debate were when Demings gave him an opening
by stepping about his legislative past.
And those are those are certainly mistakes
that she made on continuing on the issue of
gun violence.
It just was really not good for Rubio.
Speaker 2: Why are these people going out
shooting people?
This is a lot of this is the same argument
and they kill everyone.
I understand.
I want to go to Congresswoman Demings for
60 seconds.
Speaker 3: You know, people who are the families
of victims of gun violence just heard that.
And they're asking themselves, what in the
hell did he just say?
Speaker 1: Indeed.
Speaker 3: Senator, you used the the Pulse
nightclub shooting as your inspiration to
run again for the Senate in 2016.
Parkland Pulse is in my district.
And yet you've done nothing, nothing to help
address gun violence and get dangerous weapons
out of the hands of dangerous people through
Florida.
After Parkland, after you made promises that
you had no intentions on keeping to the parents
of Parkland, Florida passed legislation raising
the age to have an assault weapon passed red
flag laws that we've seen, 7000 plus instances
where they've been used.
Now to our primary responsibility is the safety
of Floridians.
And Senator, 24 years in elected office.
And you have not yet risen to that occasion.
And then when asked about it, you say something
that makes no sense.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and it didn't make any sense.
Rubio was asked multiple times, You previously
said you would support changing the age requirement
for buying a rifle, and now you don't seem
to.
Why not?
And Rubio just went in circles, never actually
acknowledging, yes, I changed my position
and here's why I changed my position and here's
why.
One of the strangest moments was when the
topic of election integrity, you know, whatever
they want to call it, they have all these
names that the name it's the name you use
already implies a particular position.
But the topic of ballot drop boxes came out
and Rubio talked about how dangerous they
are.
Speaker 2: That's a method of voting that
doesn't advantage one group or another.
There's a danger involved in drop boxes.
People need to think about it.
Imagine someone decides, Oh, there's a drop
box.
I'm just going to put some explosive in it
and blow it up and burn all of those ballots.
And now those votes don't count at all.
Why?
There is there is something with elections.
There are two things that are very important.
Number one, the count has to be accurate.
The votes have to be counted accurately.
But the other is there has to be public confidence.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So Rubio saying the reasons that ballot drop
boxes are bad are someone might bomb the drop
box.
Okay.
I mean, it hasn't happened and I wouldn't
necessarily start giving people ideas.
And he claims people don't have confidence
in the drop box as well.
The first thing has never happened and he
probably shouldn't be encouraging people to
do it, bombing a drop box.
The second thing is the reason some people
don't have confidence in drop boxes is because
people like Marco Rubio tell them that they
the drop boxes can't be trusted, that you
shouldn't have confidence in them.
It's a vicious circle.
We need voting systems that people confide
in.
And the reason people don't confide in this
one is because I told them not to.
Oh, well, stop telling them not to confide
in it.
And then we would eliminate that problem.
Rubio earlier in the debate said, you know,
on gun laws, stricter gun laws don't make
a difference because the criminals would find
a way around it.
But then he's saying, well, we got to get
rid of the drop boxes to avoid someone blowing
one up.
Well, wouldn't criminals just find a different
way to burn ballots if that's what they were
determined to do?
It doesn't really make any sense.
One more.
Clip.
The topic of abortion came up and there were
a lot of clips I could play on this.
But in the interest of time, let's look at
one in particular.
This is really kind of emblematic of the dynamic
on this issue during yesterday's debate.
Speaker 2: That you talk about Lindsey Graham's
bill, that's a four month ban that is more
lenient than every country in Europe except
for to the extremist on abortion in this campaign
is Congresswoman Demings.
She supports no restrictions, no limitations
of any kind.
Speaker 1: By the way, he said about six or
seven times that Val Demings supports no limitations.
She multiple times said, I support no limitations
up until the gestational age of viability,
which I don't.
I think it's between 21 and 26 weeks roughly.
So somewhere in there.
But he just kept repeating that lie.
Speaker 2: He voted against a form.
She's against a four month ban.
She voted against a five month ban.
She supports taxpayer funded abortion on demand
for any reason at any time up until the moment
of birth.
That's what she supports.
That's the extreme position here.
I have shown a willingness to work with people
to save unborn, innocent human life.
She opposes any limitation of any kind, and
no one ever asks them about that.
I just want to, Demings said.
Speaker 3: How gullible do you really think
Florida voters are?
Speaker 1: Well, the people voting for Rubio
are very gullible, so she's actually on to
something there.
Speaker 3: Number one, you have been clear
that you support no exceptions, even including
rape and incest.
Now, as a police detective who investigated
cases of rape and incest.
No, Senator, I don't think it's okay for a
ten year old girl to be raped and have to
carry the seed of her rapist.
No, I don't think it's okay for you to make
decisions for women and girls.
As a senator, I think those decisions are
made between the woman, her family, her doctor
and her faith.
And to sit over, to stand over there and say
that I support don't support abortions up
to the time of birth is just a lie.
But to help protect the life of the mother,
which you looked at that like it was just
well, kind of a well, that's kind of a side
issue, Senator, you know, that you have said
you don't support any exceptions.
Speaker 1: So the debate dramatically in Deming's
favor.
The question is, is it too little too late
because the polling is not particularly good
for Val Demings latest.
Real Clear Politics average of recent polling
has Marco Rubio up 4.7 points, just shy of
five points.
That is a big deficit to overcome in just
two and a half weeks.
Or how long do we have left until the election?
One to just under three weeks.
It is a deficit to overcome, but let's hope
that yesterday's debate performance will help
Val Demings overcome some of it.
One other thing.
It always happens.
You know, this this this has been going on
for so long.
When a woman like Val Demings shows up, takes
the aggressive approach, turns and looks at
Rubio when she's telling him that he's lying.
Points to Rubio.
There are always reactions that, Oh, she's
being too aggressive, she's too assertive,
etc., etc..
And the same sort of demeanor from male candidates
is often seen as powerful, commanding, indicative
of a control over the issues and the circumstances.
And there were indeed even people in my chat
yesterday saying, Oh, that Demings is coming
off too aggressive, turning this that.
The other thing I think she did I genuinely
think she did a great job.
She's a fantastic job.
One of the best debate performances so far.
Not perfect, but very, very close.
And let's see what kind of ground, if any,
Val Demings, can make up in the 20 or so days
between now and the election.
Let me know your thoughts, your reaction to
the debate.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show, of course, is a viewer,
listener, audience, community supported program.
I would love for you to sign up at join Packman
dot com.
Do the thing do the thing.
All the kids are talking about it and the
adults too I have to say mostly adults.
We actually don't have that many kids in our
audience.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com, get
access to the daily bonus show, the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show,
the members only town halls and so much more.
And you can use the coupon code Obama oh bomb
now to get a sizable discount more than 50%.
Let me leave it there.
But you've got to spell Obama now correctly,
which is sort of like correctly incorrectly
it's Obama anyway.
That's Mike Nancy Obama at join Pacman dot
com.